Salut Romain
Ça va toi ?
Wow
Ça a pas l'air d'aller là
Bah qu'est-ce qui t'arrive là ?
Ah je sais
Toi t'as encore été traîné sur Internet, t'as chopé une saloperie hein
*surpris* Putain c'est moche
*générique*
Est-ce que ça vous est déjà arrivé de sentir votre téléphone vibrer dans votre poche
D'essayer de l'attraper pour répondre et de constater que :
1. Il n'est pas votre poche, il est sur la table
et 2. Il est même pas en train de vibrer
Et bah ces vibrations fantômes c'est votre cerveau qui reçoit l'information qu'il y a une stimulation banale contre votre cuisse
et qu'il interprète comme étant une sensation qu'il connaît bien et à laquelle il s'attend
votre téléphone qui vibre.
Au point qu'il arrive à vous bluffer que vous avez vraiment l'impression de percevoir les vibrations contre votre jambe.
C'est pas vraiment une maladie mais c'est le signe que les nouvelles technologies en modifiant nos habitudes de vies
elles influencent notre esprit notre corps et donc notre santé.
Dans un autre registre,
À l'arrivée de la première Wii on a pu constater deux phénomènes :
L'augmentation des ventes de télés
et l'augmentation du nombre de tendinites liées à la manipulation de la manette.
D'ailleurs quelques années plus tôt avec l'arrivée de certains sites web à caractère récréatif on avait pu constater deux phénomènes :
L'augmentation des ventes d'essuie-tout
et l'augmentation du nombre de tendinites liées à la manipulation
...
...liées à la manipulation.
Bon j'avoue la deuxième partie c'est moi qu'ai tout inventé...
*trololo*
Dans le futur des nouvelles maladies vont apparaître
on en parlera un petit peu plus tard.
Mais les changements dans nos habitudes de vies vont aussi augmenter le nombre de cas de maladies qui existent déjà.
Un peu comme les casques de réalité virtuelle qu'ont été accusés
(alors de façon assez peu convaincante pour le coup)
de transmettre des herpès oculaires pendant les démonstrations,
vous savez quand on se les repasse de tête en tête.
En réalité l'avenir risque de nous réserver d'autres types d'infections plus sévères.
Avec la mondialisation et les progrès des transports les distances se réduisent, nos déplacements sont plus faciles
et ceux des virus et des bactéries aussi.
Et eux-mêmes évoluent et s'adaptent au monde qui les entoure.
Certaines bactéries deviennent résistantes aux antibiotiques à cause d'une trop grande utilisation de ces médicaments.
« Les antibiotiques, c'est pas automatique »
Et les virus, pareil, ils mutent, ce qui peut les rendre plus transmissibles, plus virulents et plus difficiles à soigner.
Après Ebola, l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé a d'ailleurs prévenu qu'il était urgent
que la communauté internationale change sa façon de se préparer aux épidémies futures.
« Ce truc a toujours une longueur d'avance sur nous »
« Il mute »
On est pas prêts...
Toujours au rayon des maladies qui existent déjà mais qui pourraient connaître un boum dans les années à venir
celles liées au changement climatique.
La pollution et la température vont continuer d'augmenter
et avec elles le nombre de maladies cardio-vasculaires et respiratoires mais aussi d'allergies.
dans certaines zones du globe la difficulté de s'approvisionner en eau potable va s'aggraver
et entraîner une augmentation du nombre de maladies diarrhéiques et de problèmes de malnutrition.
La cause de conditions météo qui vont leur être favorable, les moustiques risquent d'être responsables
de l'augmentation du nombre de cas de maladies comme la dengue ou le paludisme, toujours selon l'OMS.
En Chine c'est la schistosomiase, une maladie parasitaire causée par des vers,
qui pourrait profiter du changement climatique pour prendre de l'ampleur.
Ambiance hein ?
J'anime aussi les mariages, et les anniversaires !
Mais y'a pas que les maladies qui vont progresser,
la médecine aussi.
Dans un futur sans doute pas si lointain,
les nouvelles technologies feront partie intégrante de l'arsenal thérapeutique des médecins
Ce qui permettra de soigner beaucoup plus efficacement certaines pathologies.
Mais qui aura aussi ses effets secondaires.
Parmi les traitements qui vont continuer à se développer, les implants, et les prothèses.
Ce qui laisse penser au collectif « La Santé Demain » que le métalisme pourrait apparaître.
Alors le métalisme, c'est pas une société secrète qui mélange satanisme et musique saturée.
Le métalisme tel qu'il est imaginé c'est un syndrome qui toucherait les porteurs d'implant et de prothèse
et qui se manifesterait par un rejet massif de l'organisme et une intoxication aux métaux utilisés.
Comme une sorte de métallose massive
ça, ça existe déjà.
Dans un mockumentary le néerlandais Floris Kaayk décrit même une maladie purement fictive nommée Metalosis Maligna.
Dans cette pathologie les implants métalliques se mettent à grandir et remplacent les tissus humains.
Bon on est d'accord hein, ça pour le coup, c'est de la science-fiction.
Parmi les traitements très prometteurs, les nano-médicaments,
qui font l'objet de recherches et d'investissements massifs.
En gros ça consiste à mettre une substance, disons un médicament, dans une enveloppe de nano-matériaux
qui va la conduire dans notre organisme, directement au contact de sa cible,
la libérer là pour un maximum d'efficacité.
On parle même de nano-robots qui sont capables de rechercher les cellules cancéreuses
et de ne libérer le traitement que quand ils les ont trouvées.
Un des intérêts des nano-médicaments c'est leur très petite taille et leur grande précision
qui permet de diminuer les doses et les effets secondaires
Mais y'a aussi une inquiétude concernant la toxicité éventuelle des nano-matériaux
pour notre organisme et pour l'environnement.
Une autre inquiétude liée aux nano-technologies médicales c'est le risque de dérive
et la tentation de les utiliser pour améliorer l'organisme et ses performances
voire d'arriver à une sorte d'être humain augmenté avec toutes les conséquences que ça pourrait avoir.
Ce qui nous amène tout droit à un type de pathologie qu'on retrouve très souvent dans les projections sur le sujet
les pathologies psychiatriques liées aux modifications de nos modes de vie.
Comme celles liées à l'amélioration artificielle des performances dont on vient de parler
mais aussi celles liées à la surutilisation de la réalité virtuelle
qui pourrait être responsable de certaines formes spécifiques de psychoses.
Une psychose en psychiatrie c'est une maladie liée à la perturbation du rapport à la réalité
qui se manifeste notamment par des délires.
Alors pas des délires genre "wah trop délire !"
nan des délires genre "je ne sais plus ce qui est la réalité et ce qui est une production de mon propre psychisme"
*une personne très effrayée poussant des cris*
Vous voyez un peu le...?
bon, en même temps y'a 10 ans on disait la même chose des jeux vidéos alors...
Attention, avant de se quitter parce que je vous sens un peu dans le bad,
deux petites précisions.
D'abord y'a rien de certifié sur facture là-dedans.
Tout ça c'est juste des théories, des prédictions, des projections, des pistes de réflexion.
Ensuite toutes les évolutions ont leur part de positif et de négatif
Le progrès c'est une médaille qu'a son revers ça veut pas dire qu'il faut tout refuser en bloc.
En fait c'est un peu comme avec les médicaments, ils ont une certaine efficacité, qui s'accompagne de risques d'effets secondaires.
L'important c'est de s'assurer que la balance bénéfices/risques penche du bon côté et d'être vigilant.
DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo
en attendant restez cools hein, n'ayez pas peur de l'avenir
on va sûrement changer mais on va pas devenir des monstres ou des robots !
Allez, portez-vous bien.
Oups.
*générique*